humanitarian uh situation in
Gaza the loss of uh lives of innocent
civilians uh lives uh is an immense
tragedy and I would like to express uh
solidarity uh with those innocent
victims uh and their uh
families in Dev we closely follow uh the
humanitarian situation in Gaza and we
would like to use today exchange of
views uh to hear from our humanitarian
Partners as well as from uh commission
uh on the most uh pressing uh needs fac
uh by the gas and civilian population
and on EU and international humanitarian
uh
response as you know uh the commission
announced an increase of its
humanitarian assistance to over 100
billion euros for gasa this year we need
of course to ensure that these funds are
uh distrib dispersed as soon as uh
possible and reach those in need in
addition uh the EU also launched a
humanitarian airbridge uh operation to
deliver uh in kind assistance uh
including shelter food uh huding kits
and medicines among other life-saving
Aid it is however clear uh that we need
more donors uh alongside the European
Union to step up uh the efforts to help
the civilian uh population in addition
to ensuring sufficient levels of funding
uh we also need to secure safe uh
continued and unhindered humanitarian ex
access as well as humanitarian poses to
enable a delivery of humanitarian
Aid uh not only me but I think most of
us of course uh welcome the initial uh
4day uh truce agreed uh between is is
and Hamas last week and its extension uh
by two uh additional uh days uh this
temporary truths and the release of
hostages allowed for a substantial uh
increase in humanitarian Aid delivery
into and within Gaza this is something
that we can uh build on furthermore uh
it needs to be stressed that respect of
international humanitarian law uh is
crucial the protection uh of civilians
in particular hospitals its patients and
medical supplies is at the core of it
the use of course of hospitals and
civilian as human Shields by Hamas is of
course also
unacceptable but without further delay
uh I now would like to turn to our
guests and our speakers uh today uh
before giving them uh the floor I want
uh to honor uh the incredible work uh of
our humanitarian uh Partners who work
under extremely hard uh circumstances
and of course I would also like to
express my uh sympathy uh for the loss
of lives uh for so many uh Aid uh
workers but we start now I give the
floor to Miss Mara Lorenzo uh unra
representative for Europe uh six minutes
please
microphone for the speaker
please yeah can you can you hear me now
okay H I am the representative of unra
and as you know this is the largest
humanitarian actor in Gaza and what we
are seeing these days is an
unprecedented crisis that uh has
unfolded this started of course with the
night of Hamas Terror attacks on Israeli
civilians and The Taking of hostages
when I use the term unprecedented is not
a rhetorical FL flourish it's a stark
reflection of the green reality on the
ground I have been asked to provide you
with an update a humanitarian update and
I will refer to the current situation to
the response and also how EU funding is
being used uh to support us in this uh
catastrophic situation what is
unprecedented is the loss of life
according to the government media office
almost 15,000 people have been killed
73% are being children and women it's
also unprecedented the toll of unra
colleagues and I do thank you for your
sympathy in these very difficult moments
108 workers have lost their lives this
marks the highest number of un Personnel
killed in such a short short time frame
and tragicly the count can be higher
around 1.8 million people nearly 80% of
the entire population are now internally
displaced we prepare for hosting no more
than
150,000 people in our emergency
designating shelters and we have now 1.1
million people seeking protection in 156
HRA installations and I when I was
talking to my colleag today they told us
there is no more space in shelters in
recent weeks we have seen the systematic
destruction of homes hospitals mosque
churches bakeries our shelters have also
not been spur this is unprecedented 69
unra shelter some of them is schools and
some some of them more than once have
been hit including directly
hit um principles of international law
distinction proportionality and
precaution have been challenged and I
think it has also been unprecedented the
strict Siege on gasa on restrictions of
humanitarian Aid uh including when it
comes to water and food unra
commissioner General enter Gaza twice
since the start of the conflict and
during his last visit he managed to
visit the hunis training center this
institution was before providing hope
for many unemployed youth in Gaza it now
shelters
35,000 people and in the commissioner
General's own words it resembles an
overcrowded prison with super standard
living conditions threatening public
health because we are seeing sewage on
the
streets communicable diseases like skin
diseases and diarrhea uh have soore
reaching 45 times the pre-or levels in
some areas our schools as I said set
have turned into shelter designed for
1,500 people hosting now four times more
than the intended capacity there are now
3,000 to 5,000 unra staff who despite
being displaced themselves go to work to
serve the community risking their own
lives unra has continued to deliver
Health Care as shelters through 126
Medical
Teams we have received a total of
600,000 patients treated by our staff in
the 7th of October this would not have
been possible without your support Gaza
is now currently home to an estimated
50,000 pregnant women with over 180
giving birth daily midwives unra
midwives have been essential in
delivering care to postnatal and
highrisk pregnant
women we also welcome the news of a
4-day pause that the parties agreed to
and its two days Extinction it has
provided relief to civilian population
we have witnessed that in this period of
time just in the last 72 hours 20,000
more people cross down from the north to
the
South what we have been trying to do is
to access the North and for the first
time unra and humanitarian Partners were
able to distribute ready to eat food to
shelters in javala Camp as well that
tents and blankets and bottle water in
other sides our colleagues in the North
did not stop working all this time
including providing health services and
Sh Shel service and shelters this is at
a time in which we had lost
communication with them cooking gas has
entered gasa for the first time but in
very small quantities cooking g g is
essential UNR Distributing with wheat
flour but if people are not able to then
produce bread because they don't have
gas or electricity whe alone would not
make
it unra stands ready to receive more
tracks including fuel but what we need
is more humanitarian access we need more
Crossing points we reiterate our call
for a lasting humanitarian ceasefire
unimpeded and sustained humanitarian
access the lifting of the sieg on Gaza
and scale up assistance commensurate to
the needs of
people let me now Express uh my profound
gratitude for the long-standing support
of the EU and particular lead leadership
and support of echo to respond to this
crisis our thanks also goes to this
Parliament for its support and his calls
for increased funding to un's core
budget without the core budget we will
not be able to deliver on the
humanitarian crisis we consistently warn
of the dangers of Despair and distress
in Palestinian communities emphasizing
the urgency of working for a political
solution unfortunately our Appeals went
an answer leaving unra weekend this is
why your commitment to unra is is so
important and is making a real
difference your commit your your
commitment saves lives and support much
more than that it supports stability in
the
region recognizing the imperative for
Change A Renewed commitment to actively
pursue a political solution is the only
viable path to Shield future future
Generations from the recent
atrocities thank you very
much thank uh you miss Lorenzo I will
now pass the floor uh to miss Min uh
Nikolai who is msf director General you
have six minutes as well thank you
estimated members of the European
Parliament I'm grateful for the
invitation and honor to speak at this
committee asking you to do everything
within your power to ensure an immediate
and sustain ceasefire in Gaza and use
your political role to push the Israeli
government to stop the deadly attacks on
Palestinian civilians to lift The Siege
and allow crucial humanitarian Aid to
enter
Gaza though a Six-Day truth is the first
sign of humanity after weeks of
Relentless violence few days are nearly
not enough to organize the delivery of
sufficient Aid to meet the immeasurable
needs We Fear it's just a matter of days
before the mass killings of Palestinians
starts again without a Swift and
prolonged
ceasefire what will be left of Gaza and
its
people my colleagues and I like so many
people in the world were grieved and
shocked by Hamas attack to Israeli
civilians now after seven weeks Northern
Gaza is being erased from the map the
health system has
collapsed according to the Gaza Health
authorities more than 14,000 people are
dead half of which are children tens of
thousands are injured at least 1.7
million people have been displaced
according to the United Nations forcibly
ordered to move South a region also
being bombed nowhere is safe not even
hospitals msf sent an international
emergency team to Gaza to support series
of hospitals around Kan
Yunis regrettably their activities have
been severely limited due to the scale
of casualties destruction of
infrastructure lack of in essential
supplies including Fuel and the ongoing
insecurity we want and ought to be able
to do so much
more we've seen a blatant and total
disregards of the protection of gaza's
hospitals the world Health Organization
has documented
178 attacks on healthc care medical
staff including the msf staff are
utterly exhausted and Beyond despair
they've had to amputate limbs from
children suffering from severe burns
without anesthesia or sterilized
surgical tools people are dying of
pain due to the forceable evacuations by
Israeli soldiers some doctor
against medical attics have had to leave
patients behind and faced an
unimaginable Choice their lives or those
of their
patients we are watching as hospitals
are being actively targeted and turned
into
marks they are being stried shot at
encircled and raided killing patients
and medical staff resulting in an
evident violation of the 20 286 un
Security Council resolution calling for
the respect and protection of
humanitarians medical personnel medical
transports and medical facilities during
conflict three of our msf staff have
been killed many more have lost family
members and numerous colleagues have
been
injured on November 21st two msf doctors
together with a third doctor were killed
by a strike in Al AA Hospital
the day before an msf clinic in Gaza
came on fire leaving the clinic damaged
and seal several msf branded cars
destroyed on November 18th our Convoy
evacuating more than 130 staff with
their families was attacked killing one
family member and later resulting in the
death of
another how is it possible that instead
of being a century of humanity hospitals
have become the theaters of War there is
no comprehensible justification for such
atrocious
acts since 2007 Gaza is under a
blockade now it's under arbitrary
detention the Israeli government
enforced a Complete Siege on Gaza
Banning the entry of water food Fuel and
medical supplies for 2.3 civilians
Trapped In The Enclave
subjecting an entire population to
Collective punishment is a war crime as
per International humanitarian
law despite Israel's claims it's an
allout assault not being waged just on
Hamas it's being wasted on all of Gaza
and its people at all
cost even Wars have
rules we are witnessing the fundamental
principle of humanity being openly
disgraced red with the people of Gaza
being handed a death
sentence the first value of which the
European Comm Union was founded is the
inviolability of human
dignity which must be respected
protected and constitutes the real basis
of fundamental rights as members of the
European Parliament you should protect
and promote these values with concrete
actions are you doing whatever is in
your power to respect and protect the
Dignity of Palestinian people trapped
inside
Gaza I'm imploring you not to turn a
blind eye on thousands of civilians and
use your political role to adopt any
measure to Grant an immediate
ceasefire to complete lifting of The
Siege unhindered humanitarian access and
the protection of Health Facilities the
indiscriminate and Relentless attacks
must stop now the forcible replacement
ments must stop now the assaults on
hospitals and medical staff must stop
now The Siege and the restrictions on
Aid must stop now thank
you thank you uh Miss Nikolai I will now
pass the floor uh to Mr giovano D yiro
lamo who is head of unit on Middle East
at DJ
Echo thank you very much Mr chairman of
course every everyone has listened to
this quite tragic description of the
situation and if we can say that the
humanitarian truth of Po um has given
some bright of Hope of a trend we must
know that before this happened we were
serly concerned that Gaza could be
completely on the brink not only for the
almost 50,000 people killed of which
6,000 children 4,000 women but also
because after 45 of Siege and intense
bombing with so many people displaced
with so many facility water uh water
treatment facility drains uh any the
health situation as have been described
we we are afraid that we were really on
the brink of an exponential growth of
that because of course after 45 days
resilience of people start really slowly
collapsing so this this post certainly
provide some some hope but of course we
need much more extended post we need
enforc ment of international
humanitarian law we need at least 500
trucks a day coming into Gaza we need
more entry point we need a better
scanning mechanism uh we need a better
um somehow uh movement of humanitarian
operator and items within Gazza this is
essential because of course if after the
truth everything start like before uh we
we'll be again soon in the same
situation so uh DG echo of course and
European commission we we mobilize
quickly we we try to mobilize all our
partners from one side of course we we
launch our air bridge but then we also
uh we use the the the the partners which
were on the ground like KRA for example
uh to provide additional assistance to
do whatever they can but of course we
also know that humanitarian people are
at risk more than 100 human staff has
been killed so the whole situation also
require DEC conflicting
require extensive um somehow change in
the way in which uh the people can move
within GSA now is um the the
quadruplication of humanitarian
assistance seems an enormous step done
by us and actually it is in the current
budgetary situation but at the same time
uh we have to understand that the needs
we could find in Gs are when the
situation will be more um conducive to
proper uh distribution of Aid could be
much worse because of course when you
have the displacement of almost to one
1,00 milon 500,000 to two thou 2 million
people and then when you have the such
massive destru infrastructure the
situation will be will be uh facing in
the coming days even if the situation uh
in terms of humanitarian post remain uh
better will also be very difficult so I
also want to thank not not only the
parliament for the interest but also the
member states which not only have
supported us in new allocation of funds
but also they have um launched a number
of bilateral actions which also could
allow to have as Europe as team Europe
and a massive maneuver which should
allow us to to have a significant impact
on the ground but of course every time
we are in close contact with all the
partners even if they work for us or not
to get more information and more somehow
up update uh knowledge of the situation
on the ground but I think that we we we
have seen something completely different
which since long time uh a crisis that
this kind was not felt in this kind of
proportion so thank you very
much thank you uh and I will uh soon
open up uh the floor for the uh
political uh groups uh but I would
firstly like to give uh the floor to our
standing raur on humanitarian Aid Mr
Carlos uh serindu please you have the
floor thank you very much uh for your
testimony which gives substance and
confirms the oror that we read in the
press and see on TV these hostilities
are causing a number of deaths and
suffering that shock the world and hurt
our
hurs in the European Parliament we have
given a voice to people who suffer and
we demanded the full application of the
Primacy of International humanitarian
law we did it in Dev committee and in
the plenary and we do it again here
today thank you president you approved a
strategy for humanitarian head that
propos more resources and methodologies
for more effective
implementation that is true an
implementation need to be done right now
we are on day 54 52 of this war with
more than
6,000 dead most of them human and
children the Gaza STP is under heavy
fire and around 80% of his inhabitants
are currently displaced escaping for a
brutal attack that destroys everything
and everyone more than un agents have
been killed since the beginning of the
war and more than 60 journalists have
lost their lives in the territory never
in this it history as United Nations l
so many agents on the ground in such a
short time it is essential to ensure a
platform for dialogue between Israel and
amas to achieve a definitive
humanitarian ceasefire that allows
humanitarian head to effectively enter
in Gaza guaranteeing the surv survival
and lives of civilians and at the same
time the safety of humanitarian actors
The Siege and attack on Gaza constitute
a clear and unacceptable violation of
international humanitarian law a
solution for a sustainable future for
region is urgently needed which must
involve the existence of two states
which Israel and Palestine leing side by
side thank
you thank you Carlos and we will
continue now with the political groups
and start with EP
Yanka um thank you very much um I will
speaking
polish
um thank you very much I would I'd like
to say that the images from Gaza Strip
really move me and I've seen quite a lot
of dreadful images about 10 years ago
with uh polish humanitarian Aid well
we've been helping out to providing
assistance in different conflicts I have
worked in the Gaza Strip and West Bank
but what I've seen recently I've never
seen before and if you take a look at
the figures we've heard the Fig in the
in the St uh statistics being given and
we have to think how we can help these
people survive through these very
difficult times how can we help and
support the organizations that are
actually on the ground at the moment to
the lady representing
on I'd like to know just how many other
organizations uh who have
resources um to help are are they there
in Gaza what is the possibility to
actually get more humanitarian Aid there
and what's going to happen in two days
time because the pause has been extended
for two days so what happens after two
days is there going to be more bombing
are more people going to die and are we
going to see these even more tragic
historic uh stories like the hospital
being bombed and the sto everything
we've heard from the msf which is an
example of how hospitals are being
attacked how can we support and help
these
people and how can we get this Aid to
them we had started to develop a plan
but for a time of stability uh for Gaza
stripp but also for Israel uh because of
course these situations are linked thank
you thank you anina uh s Monica you
would like to take the
floor yes thank you very much
chair I'd just like to repeat and also
support what the rapporter has said Mr
zinia when it comes to the humanitarian
situation and the question I have for
the commission echo in particular we
know that the commissioner at the last
plenary in Strasburg
was saying that obviously we're looking
for new corridors new entry points for
humanitarian
Aid so I'd just like to know what lines
are you working on we are the principal
donor together with the Palestine
Palestinian Authority so obviously we
have to bring our weight to bear in
these negotiations and talks and see
whether the uh pause can be extended and
I think the political forces here in the
parliament must try and do that as I
said as one of the main donors to
Palestine so thank you very much and
obviously uh we have our support we can
give you our support we can't just stick
to uh rhetorics and talk we have to
really do something about the Dreadful
situation that the whole Palestine is
going through thank you thank you Monica
for the renew group Barry
Andrews yeah just to thank the uh
presenters in the Comm
uh for their um uh testimony this
morning this this evening um I uh had
share with the other uh MEPS um just
continuing horror at what we're
observing uh this short pause um is
really just not good enough and uh we
need to see an extension um the number
of debts has reached a level that is uh
so far departed from any uh
proportionality as to really raise the
question of whether or not we can uh we
can stand by to watch this happen day by
day if it resumes in the in the next few
days um I want to just ask a practical
question about uh the Rafa
Crossing um as far as I understand it
and briefed by unra before is that Rafa
isn't necessarily a freight Crossing uh
in normal
circumstances uh there were five or six
other Crossing between Israel and Gaza
uh and when we talk about 500 trucks
that are needed that they habitually
crossed all of these Crossings before
October the 7th and now trying to
squeeze them into one Crossing where
there is uh where they don't have the
facilities perhaps you could just
elaborate on why Rafa even if uh the
government of Israel were allowing
humanitarian Aid to cross even if uh
that was the case that it would not be
possible to uh to to reach the level of
humanitarian Aid that's required um
maybe the commission could tell us a
little bit about the Cypress Corridor
the maritime Corridor that we've heard
about um are you putting ins sufficient
effort to try to uh make that happen
there's been some talk but no action
frankly and we need to see that uh
addressed and finally I would like to
ask um uh unra and msf to comment on the
efforts that the government of Egypt are
making uh to relieve the pressure on the
population of Gaza thank
you thank you Barry and for the greens M
Rose thank you very much chair thank you
very much to those who have spoken and
given us a um state of
play some MEPS have uh spoken on the
humanitarian Aid which is in course and
we've got this extension of two days
which is very good news of the aid of
the ceasefire
rather
[Music]
and you have spoken about the fact that
the
pause should evolve into a sustainable
permanent
piece we have various stakeholders
who've come and spoke Spen about the
fact that the international law is not
being respected in this
regard and thousands of children are
suffering under the bombs you gave a
63%
percentage we have to protect those also
who are working in there and providing
humanitarian
assistance um it's it's not enough we
know that we see that uh
bakeries uh places where they could uh
have access to food and also to fuel is
just in existence uh this is collective
punishment uh and it seems to be going
on and on so I have some questions about
the humanitarian Aid which colleagues
have not yet brought up the possibility
for example of these
corridors
and and uh the Via Cyprus for example a
maritime Corridor apparently that will
be opened up is the European commission
going to take into consideration that
the Cyprus uh route
uh would take place
uh is the European Union really applying
pressure to open up these other points
of Entry
and as we've
heard from the United
Nations
why have these issues not yet been dealt
with uh in the European
Union in in regard to this passage of
Aid is the European Union
also monitoring the situation in the
West Bank and the violence which is
breaking out there thank you thank you I
see no one from from ECR and from ID but
I have from the left uh next in round is
Miguel uban creso please for two
minutes yes thank you very much
chair it's true that if you look at the
Dreadful humanitarian situation in Gaza
it's not the result of uh a natural
disaster it's the result of the
collective punishment that's being Meed
out on the Palestinian population a
collective punishment which is is
breaking any kind of international
humanitarian law and thanks to the
impunity uh granted by the United States
and European Union on Israel and it's a
disaster which is the result of an
infrahuman situation where you have
there's no water energy or uh medical
supplies going into Gaza Strip and this
is a result of bombs that have killed
more children than all the wars last
year so we have a humanitarian disaster
where we've seen that journal and
humanitarian Aid workers are being
killed and it's a disaster that is the
result of attacks on hospitals and
schools humanitarian disaster uh which
is uh looks very much like ethnic
cleansing and this is not going to end
with the supply of humanitarian Aid what
do we need we need to use all the
mechanisms and tools under International
humanitarian law to bring Israel to Halt
this attack and uh they DEC de ades of
occupation and AAR hide on Palestine if
the European Union really wants to put
an end to the situation in Gaza then
they all they have to do is Implement
and apply international law which
includes an embargo on arm supplies
suspend the preferential agreement with
Israel until the systematic violations
of human rights have come to an end and
an end also to the occupation of
Palestinian ter uh territory territory
otherwise he just putting a Band-Aid uh
on somebody throwing bombs at you so I
have three questions and obviously thank
you to all the wonderful work that you
do how can you explain the high number
of unreal workers that have been killed
assassinated has this happened in other
conflicts or is it only happening
here because there are different
reporters from United n Nations Pedro
Aro uh who have now said that uh there
is the possibility that genocide is
being perpetrate perpetrated in Gaza
Strip which is a harsh word so I'd like
to know what you think of that and
thirdly when it comes to your own
opinion and international law what about
the military strategy of cutting off
supplies energy humanitarian Aid to over
two and a half million people what can
you call that under international law
thank you we have one for the nonin
street but we have two more members uh
for for minute to intervene before we
come back to our uh interlocutors so s
Ramos for a minute
please yes thank you very
much I would I also like to thank the
representatives of
Ona Med Frontier and I would also like
to well
apologize almost because we belong to an
international organization the European
union and I would like to apologize for
the fact that we have not been able to
act energetically enough to be able to
respect international law um because
we've seen that a lot of humanity of Aid
workers have been killed and they went
into this work they were didn't know
before they did so that they were going
to have to pay with their lives for
helping people in these conflicts I do
have a couple of questions one that
comes to the crossing points the
corridors for humanitarian Aid the
commission has said yes increase
humanitarian aid four-fold but if the
aid can't get in there is the the Shalom
passing between Israel and Gaza Strip
that is the one that accounted for about
60% of uh Freight and trade going
through before this uh Dreadful Carnage
is there any kind of negotiation with
Israel for that particular passing point
to be
opened and what is the how far we've got
with a possible agreement with
Cyprus uh which would allow thousands of
tons of Aid being able to get through
even though we know that the port
facilities in Gaza are very small scale
and have been bombed so I would just
like to know what your vision is of that
particular perspective thank you thank
you Z and for a brief uh addition Monica
Gonzalez yes thank you very much chair
to for giving me the floor again another
question which I feel is important given
that the Israeli government in the
middle of a human unprecedented
humanitarian uh situation is has bombed
DG EO installations in um West Bank uh
how is the commission going to react
because of course this is endangering
thousands of lives so that's a question
to the commission but then of course we
know that your Aid workers are losing
their lives as well so how is
this because we've got the situation in
the West Bank as well and how is that
affecting the work that your
organizations are doing that you uh we
will now go back to the three uh
speakers we had uh before and we are
very good in in time management so we
can stick to the uh even it's just five
minutes but hopefully you uh can fill
these five minutes with a lot of uh
answers to the questions and we start
with Mrs Loreno from unra please floor
is
yours thank you I will try to answer as
many questions as I can I think we heard
from the the EP how um what other
organizations are doing uh in Gaza of
course we don't work in isolation but it
is very clear that unra is by far the
largest humanitarian actor first because
we have been there for 75 years second
because we have 13,000 employees in Gaza
so this is not a small number but we
work under the coordination of the
humanitarian country team where you have
un agencies and other uh Nos and of
course we work in coordination in direct
coordination with Echo on very
operational and strategic issues so
coordination is happening and there are
other organizations that are on the
ground but we should not forget that
before the Gaza War started it was unra
that was providing food Aid assistance
in kind assistance to 1.2 million people
so we are still the largest agency but
of course wfp UNICEF un women un FBA are
other important H actors um what can be
done what after to is very difficult to
predict our ask is that we don't go back
to where we were where where we were
because this is horror and how much
horror a civilian population can stand
when we know that we don't we don't have
any more space in our shelters in fact
the commissioner General described it as
prisons because we had to lock them
because there is no much much more space
for anybody else so we don't want to go
back to a situation where there is no
food when there is no water when we have
to beg for fuel so human scale up
humanitarian assistance is what we need
and this takes me to what other options
are available on the table obviously the
Rafa crossing point is not the solution
this place was not meant to be uh um a
um a crossing point for Commodities we
need more Crossing points and we don't
need to reinvent the whe because Karen
Shalom was there in the first place and
this is the the one place that has a
scanning capacity to allow a scale up
humanitarian assistance so our call is
to use what was existing before the war
is starting because this is available
and this is simple uh another simple
solution is the restoration of basic
supplies including electricity and water
for which I have always repeated we do
not need tracks we we need a
longstanding humanitarian ceasefire that
allow us to conduct basic repairs of the
water Network so that we are able to
restore water supplies and as I said
this does not need
tracks um so that needs lifting the the
seege um on Egypt I we have found a very
good partner uh but I am not aware of
the details of the negotiations with
with egyp so perhaps others can uh come
in but in terms of relieving the
pressure I think we have found a very
good partner when it comes to the
coordination of humanitarian ER
assistance how is it possible that there
were so many un um uh workers killed in
this conflict as simp because they were
not killed while do doing their
humanitarian work they were killed in
their homes they were killed in their
homes with their entire families uh and
and it is very difficult to protect
humanitarian workers when there is no
place to flee in Gaza and and many
people chose to stay in their homes and
they were killed in their homes
um I will leave to the commission the
issue of the maritime uh Corridor
um yes human I think on the on the
comment made by the left uh
Urban you said that humanitarian
assistance is not the solution no
humanitarian assistance it's only
helping us mitigate the suffering of
civilians in Gaza but it is not the
solution the solution is a longest
standing ceasefire the solution is not
to go back to where we were when the war
started with 16 years of blockade and
with no hope for Palestinian civilians
and with dist trust and fear
by the Israeli population so there needs
to be much more than that and it's only
a just a lasting uh political solution
that is going to bring back uh peace uh
in in the
region
[Music]
um I I think the last question from
Monica was on how is the current
situation in the in the West Bank
affecting our operations well they are
disrupted that's the short answer uh we
we have seen a total closure of the West
band made restrictions of movement and
that makes it very very difficult for
our operations to continue operations
mean uh um the school system to continue
obviously when you have teachers and
school children needing to cross
checkpoints this is not possible in the
current situation and yes we keep our
facilities open but this does not mean
that life is normal in the Westbank Bank
we have seen raids in refugee camps we
have seen detentions we have seen 45
children uh uh being killed children
being detained and I was speaking today
in an event organized by by this by a
parliament member here on Detention of
children this is what is happening right
now in in in the West Bank and makes it
very very difficult for people to have
um a normal life I stop there six
minutes
perfect uh thank you so much for these
answers and we continue directly with
Miss Nikolai
please thank you um yeah some of the
questions were really for negotiations I
think for the UN or or the commission so
I'll take um uh the points that I can
address so how can we help the first
intervention from the lady um how can we
help well that's what I said as as
members of parliament you can help with
your political voice
to insist on uh a prolonged a a true
immediate sustained ceasefire and that
ceasefire is important for also
humanitarian AIDS because otherwise we
will not be able to scale up to address
the needs and that goes together with
lifting The Siege so as parliamentarians
you can um bring that up and impose uh
those ceasefires together with other
parts in the
world um yes I agree with you a short
pause uh you were saying is not enough
completely greets that's why we ask for
a sustained uh ceasefire on the comment
on Egypt um it's a complex situation
it's Rafa border as you was saying it's
it's small it was not meant for Freight
so you have Kum Shalom but you have
others so we agree with some of the
others to open more Crossings but
lifting The Siege overall is very
important for us it's also complex who
exactly holds which key because the the
negotiations are are difficult so the
United Nations have vo and as the
Egyptian red cresant we have been able
to pass 24 uh metric tons of a this last
already before this um this Truth uh and
and the last days we've brought in a bit
including just food uh for our own staff
because they don't have enough let alone
that you can bring in your medical
supplies and the Very needed fuel I want
to to highlight that fuel is crucial uh
for the running of hospitals for uh
running water pumps uh sewage systems
and all that and that's all impacting
Public Health as we know so with Egypt
we uh we're also looking into now uh
caring for wounded they have agreed to
have a surgical team in to work uh close
uh to that Raa Crossing so these are
negotiations
ongoing uh so I'm not saying here that
it's being blocked um the other points
so unra staff called our doctors were
killed were on duty I want to be very
clear there so the attack on ala
Hospital there were three doctors
standing behind the window uh uh
something uh I cannot classify exactly
what kind of arm it was entered the
building and killed the three doctors in
one go uh and two of them were msf
doctors um yeah what is uh attributing
to military The Med medical military
strategy is it amounting to uh uh you
mentioned war crimes Etc I think you
manage yourself Collective punishment of
uh of people I've mentioned it forceful
displacement um and then I think uh what
I I highlighted as well is the attack on
medical Mission there is a UN resolution
2,286 after our attack on kundus we've
been pleading very strongly uh that the
UN Security Council would take that up
again uh to uh preserve the medical
Mission by uh the Personnel the patients
the infrastructure that should not be
under attack and I think again as
parliamentarians you can say something
about it last thing I wanted to say on
uh West Bank uh I didn't address it
absolutely is a catastrophic situation
as well our teams are working in Janine
in the hospital we've had over the last
few few weeks several times that the
entry to the hospital has been blocked
ambulances have been blocked entrance to
the to the hospital which is absolutely
not acceptable um so we see a lot of
incursions uh in the Janine Camp so the
the the teams of msf are working in jine
in the hospital uh trying to help as
well in the camp to bring help there
first aid as well as in nablo and heon
and other places in the West Bank
situation is also very
complicated also to you thank you very
much Miss Nikolai and uh we also have
again Mr D U please take the
floor yes thank you so uh just to go in
order trying to reply to all your
concern um of course
um we we we are looking um in a way to
be fast in delivering Aid so the first
reason why there was this qu duplication
of the aid is essentially to be ready so
thanks to that we we have been able to
provide additional Financial Resources
to the partner like umra wfp wh Red
Cross um UNICEF uh Norwegian refug
Council Etc who can um within the
existing uh tools they have on the
ground they have been able to deliver
more Aid and actually when the
humanitarian post was established we had
the possibility to quickly step up the
um the aid however of course is very
much insufficient it's clear and the
present system is very complex so to
give you an idea items survive inish in
the Sinai Peninsula on Mediterranean
Coast they respected there then they go
back to Rafa where is a second
inspection when they have been cleared
and sealed they go down to nitsana which
is down the border between Israel and
Egypt in Nana they are respecting again
sealed and then sent back to Rafa Rafa
of course was a previously were used for
movement of people more than massive
movement of goods so has been adapted in
somehow repaired and then once in GSA
they go to large facility can be
facility of dur ler Qatari uh soal
katari um Depot and there are number
weight so by which uh with great bravery
uh un and others try to convey the a
within gatza so there is a definitely we
need more entry point before there were
plenty of say plenty but there were some
entry points along the is guards a
border we of course pass the message to
Israeli that is important also to
increase for the time being the the
reply is no just to be frank so it's go
beyond what humanitarian Branch or
european commission can do but of course
we continue our advocacy explaining and
using the argument uh that of course a
certain moment it becomes exponential
and become impossible to control for
anyone when people if there an epidemics
or whatever the number of death could be
to grow up much bigger than it is now so
then uh of course other option other
option okay Maritime Corridor of course
Maritime also deserve and we have
putting a lot of attention in this and
certainly Cyprus could be very close
operational basis with all the facility
Etc very close to the Middle Eastern
region however um you need the some form
of the conflicting you cannot send ships
very close to Goda to be then in the
middle of a fight the ship are very
vulnerable when they close to the to to
cost by the way there's a problem also
of deep water Port so in Gazza uh Port
facility are not adequate so you need
some form of trans shipment which is
also complex then of course also you can
in the meantime send more massive Aid to
um to Lish by both that's a possibility
so all this is studied they are
technical issue but at the core of it
course you need some form of poses to
operate properly and this all not only
for entering GZA but also for
Distributing within Gaza because of
course when you have this such an
intense bombing and such a high volume
of U of no the destructive power uh and
chain on on on civilian infrastructure
you need a certain moment to stop to
adjust possibility of moving within the
Gaza street but they they're doing it so
people risking their life to to to
provide assistance there are in GZA and
they continue to do that uh then there
was another question concern I think
West Bank yes of course we monitor West
Bank through our Jerusalem office and
through our partners we are very active
in the West Bank we have a number of
specialized engo in legal protection in
trying to know block the when possible
um eviction and demolition Etc however
uh in West Bank what we saw after the
7th October is an exponential growth of
that
there are since then 230 Palestinian
kills and almost 3,000 seriously injured
so this is something unprecedented of
course in the West Bank there was a
growing during last year increase of
violence uh vigilante
violence against no villagers Etc but
sometime it's um no intervention by the
the Army but however this is something
the volume now is much more serious of
course there is a con concern for the
West Bank and we hope of course and we
of course we advocate for restraint this
is also something uh that is done and um
but of course staying within our
humanitarian role then other part of the
commission of the European external
Action Service or other have of course
the possibility to to to to go more
political in this sense so this also
something important
and I don't remember it was a for
question but I'm not sure to have keep
of them but don't if there is anything
anything else I think which commission
was
addressed about this uh
sorry well if if if it is very brief you
can you can remind the uh the colleague
otherwise uh you have to chitchat uh
just after the
meeting no as I was saying it was a
question on C Jordan of the Left Bank
has the commission
prepare to reply uh against the attack
that we on in the West Bank well
I
well we can continue to um our advocacy
of course uh we continue to provide
funds for protection in the West Bank
and uh even there of course this is a
political discussion goes to a certain
extent Beyond humanitarian needid so in
this moment I'm not really in the
position we are going to do this and
that because these other branches of the
European institution will be operating
on that but certainly we provide data we
provide information we know what's
happening on the ground we monitor on
daily basis what's happened there and we
in the limit of course of our mandate we
tell of course our Israel counterpart
that they uh there is a serious problem
there and I understand that of course
some parts of of the societ is aware of
it to the risk and so it's because also
situation who can go easily out event
and concerning Jordan in particular so
Jordan is also active and there too of
course there is a conference in a man on
the 30 of November in which coordination
for to gods that will be
discussed perfect thank you very much uh
fortunately the interpreters uh gave us
a couple of uh extra minutes so thank
you for that so that we can can conclude
also because we have uh Mr yanek uh in
the room from the es he's the deputy
head of Middle East Division and of of
course would be delighted to also have
your information if you can briefly
comment within two minutes also on the
issue thank
you uh thank you very much Mr chairman
uh honorable uh members let me um start
by commending the work of our partners
in particularly unva um in dealing with
the tremendous challenges on the ground
uh I also would like to join words of
sympathy that have been also said here
by many uh regarding the loss of life of
unaa members there are over 100
colleagues that have died um during the
tragic events that we have seen in the
past weeks uh on our side let me say
perhaps a word I could recall the EU
position which of course was discussed
at the highest level by EU leaders um
that have that has been Consolidated uh
in the October European Council
conclusions that of course is firstly to
emphasize Israel's right to defend
itself in the face of the brutal and IND
discriminator attacks but also to
emphasize the need to respect
international law and international
humanitarian law uh you leaders were
also very clear on the utmost importance
to ensure the protection of civilians at
all times and everywhere and of course
they have also expressed particularly
grave concerns for the deteriorating
humanitarian situation in Gaza uh and
have called for continued and rapid and
safe unhindered humanitarian access to
reach those uh in a need um of course um
as has been said here it's also very
important for us to think about the long
term and EU leaders have also been very
clear about that the EU position has
translated in very concrete work
strengths for all the institutions um
the high representative and vice
president borell has been personally
extremely engaged on this and has
followed on the work strands also uh
with the help of the foreign ministers
in the Foreign Affairs Council he has
recently come back from the region as
you know because he debriefed the the
European Parliament a couple of days ago
he visited Israel Palestine bahin Qatar
Saudi Arabia as well as Jordan and he
discussed these issues with regional
leaders how to uh improve the
humanitarian situation but also how to
work on the long term yesterday he
co-chaired the union for the
Mediterranean meeting with the Jordanian
counterpart where they discussed exactly
the same issue the whole meeting was in
fact focused on on the situation in the
Middle East uh perhaps uh briefly on the
fac work strength that I mentioned
because of course humanitarian situation
is one of the three issues um that the
focus is particularly concentrated on uh
my colleague from the commission has
already mentioned the EU work on on on
on this uh wig strand the high
representative was very clear from the
beginning in his call and in his support
to the call by the UN Secretary General
gues um we have also been very clear in
in in our call to support the
implementation of the UN Security
Council resolution that was adopted um a
couple of days ago in in New York and of
course now we have like others welcomed
the the 4-day pause uh with the release
of of the hostages and of course uh very
much welcome the extension and hope for
more um for for more extension and of
course um continued efforts to release
all the hostages um the second work
strand perhaps is worth mentioning as
well because of course foreign ministers
are very much focused on making sure
that um the situation doesn't spread in
the region um that there's no uh
spillover that includes the West Bank
that was also um particular question by
a couple of parliamentarians and my
colleague from the commission has
already mentioned uh the situation in
the West Bank is very much followed also
by the high representative himself and
of course the whole um external action
service the high representative has
discussed this um in quite detail also
in in Israel with with the counterparts
and raise these issues personally with
the
interlocutors and third perhaps last is
really the the for us the the need to
think about the long term it's very hard
because of course everybody's focus is
on the immediate needs now in Gaza as
has been very much described in detail
here by the colleagues but of course
part of our work is to ensure that we
start the Reflections about the long
term um and discuss the um the the the
the new de new development in in Gaza in
connection also with the two-state
solution uh in Palestine and of course
the high representative is very much
engaged in trying to revive the the
political process part of that is of
course our support to the Palestinian
Authority because we have been also very
clear that they are our legitimate
partners and will continue um our
support
thank you very much thank you so much Mr
yanek and uh I extend these thanks to
all the speakers we had here
distinguished guest for these uh
insightful uh views you you shared with
us uh in this very important uh um
minute and of course uh on behalf of the
whole committee I would like to pass on
these SS and U be be aware that we will
uh closely follow the humanitarian
situation in Gaza as the David committee
uh with this we can move on to item
number uh 12 which is is any other
business is there something that needs
to be raised if not then item number 13
is that the next meeting is on December
7th uh from 9 to 10:00 and with this I
close the meeting have a great
evening thank you so much for no
problem in really appreciate no no no no
no no don't worry that's that's fine we
can always count on but we don't abuse
you
great
e